I feel like the news made things very
confusing the news started becoming like
not information and a lot of people got
extremely scared and didn't know who to
believe anymore well here you go you
want the answer to the news yeah Jesse
has it yeah I'd like a you know I
wouldn't mind a dose of it man because
that's where I feel like a lot of bad
information started downfall of the news
came with the show 60 minutes
now you guys are all going to sit and
don't know
how could you 60 minutes that's an
award-winning investigative reporting
show which it is and it's a great show
it was a great show still is probably a
great show but 60 Minutes was the
downfall of the American Media was that
when they started editorializing it
ah
prior to 60 Minutes all the news lost
money
and they made up for it in the
entertainment Division and that was a
standard rule the news is to educate the
news just to do this the news don't make
money it's to inform
Along Came the show 60 Minutes it shot
to number one in the ratings The Bean
counters eyes got big and they went you
mean we can make money off the news yeah
that's what 60 Minutes cost making
profit off the news then it became about
ratings rather than informing now the
news is nothing but entertainment right
so it's there to get ratings points it's
there to make money for advertisers
where in the days of Walter Cronkite
back when I was even younger than you
the news lost money you want the show
that were so ahead of its time the movie
that it's scary today for me to watch it
watch the show Network yeah with Faye
Dunaway uh William Holden I've seen that
it's good and Peter Finch won the
Academy Award for playing Howard Beale
because he just got so real and that's
and it changed everything no that's
where it became entertainment remember
they brought Faith done away in from
entertainment yes to get the race he was
the new producer and this was done
before it ever happened to the news yeah
they call it to her desk and see she's
like I knew 60 Minutes it changed it
yeah so that movie whoever wrote the
script or whatever
was was looking into the future and had
their thumb right on the button wow
because that's what our media or our
news has turned into the movie network
so then but it's all about ratings
points now guys it ain't about making
you smarter or giving you information
it's about till late look at right now
what's the big news out there right now
another missing white girl yeah
now if that girl was black you think
they'd be all that front page stories
every night if it was a black hiking
really though but maybe probably not
maybe not you know maybe not black girls
disappear every day yeah and you don't
see though where they ice every all
people disappear every day probably but
why is it that they pick out
and don't get me wrong it's a tragedy
it's horrifying whatever happened to her
don't get me wrong on that no totally
understand the media's coverage of it
it's okay when I was gonna do the show
for MSNBC everything comes down from on
high they tell you what they're like
Hannity in these guys they get told what
to talk about oh totally yeah you know
well I fought them you know what they
sent me every day Lacey Peterson what
and I said that's a tragedy but there's
ten thousand murders a year why is this
one exceptional and why should people in
Minnesota or in the east coast care
about a murder that took place out in
California yeah yes we feel sad Lacey
was murdered like I feel sad that
anybody else gets murdered but why would
I on a national TV show
give five minutes of the show's time
covering a murder that affects that when
you have ten thousand of them a year
yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one